i think i've been pretty vocal about
this that i haven't had a car in 10
years
10 years i haven't had a car i always
wanted a mercedes i never i always had
like
in high school i had like the worst car
in high school i went to this i got a
scholarship to this you know private
high school in miami miami country day
shout out to the spartans out there
and um i just my mom's old jalopy that
she gifted to me the color was rust it
was the the nickname was blinky because
one headlight was up and one was down it
was just like
this mess of a car and then i finally
when i went to college i got another car
and i was doing uh food deliveries and
the car would always break down it was a
mess so finally when i started to make a
little bit of money i said i always
wanted a mercedes bro
i always wanted a mercedes i was um
i just turned 30 and i just i probably
was 27 28 when i really started making
money well at that time i had made six
figures which was cool for me so i said
all right
i'm gonna get a car and my buddy was
actually selling his old mercedes it was
an older mercedes but it was my roommate
in college i loved this car
and um
i bought the car off of him i go how
long is this car to last because it had
a hundred thousand miles on it two years
bro
two years two years that's what he said
he said i've had the car he said it'll
last two years it'll last two more it
was it was uh the car was already 10
years old oh yikes and i had 100 000
miles it was an older mercedes i loved
his car yeah yeah and one year in
highway drama
i'm like [ __ ] this
thing's the worst i ended up selling the
car for like 3 000 bucks and just i said
let me see how long i could go
without
having a car and that summer was the
summer
that my boy
chris humphries
married kim kardashian and i was out
there in l.a doing the whole kardashian
thing i'll save those details for
another time but i was in la for the
summer okay we were going to mexico we
were living our best life i i had
literally had drivers it was pre uber
and um
it was awesome so i came back to florida
i said all right i haven't had a car in
two three months let's see how long i
could go all right i was taking the
train i was just doing doing what i
could without a car
10 years later i haven't had a car right
so i've saved a ton of money
i've invested a ton of money yeah right
and things are doing okay now since then
uber and lyft is everywhere instacart
during covenant you ain't going anywhere
so
it just it's treated me very well now
this doesn't work for everybody like
people say because i lived in downtown
miami
and everything was around me
and anywhere i needed to go of course i
would just i would uber there it was
convenient and obviously i have like
inroads and i have friends in the
nightlife business i would go and meet
them i'd be drinking the last thing i'm
gonna do is trying to catch a dui right
like i think i was the only one of my
friends in college that i lived with a
group of guys from miami the only one
that didn't get a dui
so i've seen the dui thing happen yeah
it's it's it's actually absurd these
days that people get duis with
freaking uber out there and lyft like
dude so many options 10 000 is what it
calls for a dui and you're worried about
a 30 uber what are we talking about now
yeah so
point is i haven't had a car in 10 years
and what i always talk about is
all right so it's not just the car
payment do you know the average car
payment for a new car in america
to 400 bucks it's over that it's over
550 bucks for a new car for a used car
the average car payment is 400 bucks but
it's more than just the car payment
right it's the gas it's the insurance
it's the maintenance it's the repairs
it's the taxes it's the tolls it's the
fees it's the registration it's the
parking
it's the god forbid you get a dui all
that
and it just adds up so i saw this
article i said you know what this
article basically
is what i'm talking about here so if
you're paying 500 bucks for your car
as a monthly payment
that's
500 bucks so that's six grand a year in
car payments okay but this article right
here
says the true cost of ownership for a
new car
is ten thousand dollars a year the true
cost of ownership when you add up
everything
car payment the depreciation
the interest the insurance the
maintenance the gas and that's just if
everything goes according to plan god
forbid you get an accident or a flat
tire or a dui
it goes up from there so the so the
average car ownership they call it the
uh
tco the true cost of ownership
is 9
just shy of 10
grand so every year aaa conducts a
survey to determine the true cost of car
ownership in 2020 the number was 9 500
and now this year it's
96.66 so it's going up and it's only
going to go up so my days
oh
yeah this is what happens right there
some uh
for trees
the trees in the house the trees
in the house our guide so that's the
point and then
so
so i ask yourself
five five ten years ago the thought of
not having a car was unfathomable yeah
insane you need to get to work you need
to go places you need to go get the
groceries you need to
do everything you got to do you got to
run errands these days
these days
with a lot of people living in
cities right obviously if you live out
in the country you're going to need
something maybe you know yeah living in
cities
amazon deliveries instacart
covid
shutdowns things not being open you not
wanting to be around people
cars are a little bit i would i would
say overrated at this point
yeah i don't know it all depends never
was there a time before
that you didn't necessarily have to have
a car now you might be saying i live
kind of far from work i don't
necessarily i can't do this
i get it but never in the last i don't
know 50 years has it not been this easy
to not have a car that's my point you
have a car yeah i know sometimes i'm
like
so david uh what time you're getting out
of here yeah yeah yeah
um
and obviously uh so it would be your
benefit if i
were to keep my car yeah
anyway but anyway the true cost of
ownership
is no that's saluda about 10 000 a year
so if you make 50 grand a year 20 of
your income is going to your car
20 percent it's a lot of it's a lot of
a lot of dough it's a lot of dough to
roll around in style anyway so here's
and then what i saw this article this is
from value penguin it's basically
valley penguin right penguin not
valuetainment valuetainment's mascot
right there
penguin
are you paying one shout out so when i
saw this article i said all right if the
car payment is the
most expensive what's the next
and then car insurance was there so i
broke it down like this it says these
are the states
that
have the most expensive
car insurance and these are the states
that have the least
expensive cost for car insurance so now
i don't want to go through all 50 of
them but let's just go through the top
five can we do that let's do it yes sir
top five here we go let's start from the
five
on up the fifth most expensive state is
missouri at eighteen hundred and ninety
five dollars a year for car insurance
number four
california
one thousand nine hundred and sixty six
dollars a year
number three here in florida
a year in florida third most just for
car insurance
three thousand
michigan number two
twenty one hundred dollars and number
one this is by far it's not even
freaking close it blows everything else
out of the water
oftentimes because they are getting
blown out of the water it's louisiana
with 2 800
okay that's obviously has to do with
hurricanes
and uh
things that happened there that uh i
assume that's the the situation there
with louisiana um
so if you're in those states
and you're spending two almost three
thousand dollars on car insurance
that's literally what i spend a year on
uber
just to put it in perspective okay i
spent about i've always wondered yeah i
was gonna ask you eventually like is he
actually
yeah way less than having a car well
keep in mind when i was working from
home like a lot of people are when i was
before i was coming into valuetainment
every day i was working from home i've
been working remote for five six years i
spent
maybe a hundred dollars a month on uber
a month
a month because i worked from home i
lived in a nice condo my gym was in the
condo like i lived downtown miami
anywhere i needed to go the miami heat
arena to go to heat games or
the museum it was all right there
downtown like if you live in new york
city you understand what i'm talking
about i lived in downtown miami okay
exactly you lived at biscayne exactly so
it was very easy i would instacart i
would amazon i literally spent no money
the only time i would go out
uh and i'd go out you know hit south
beach go out i would uber but even if i
had a car i'd still be ubering
right like i'm still going out drinking
i'm not gonna uber to the club i'm sorry
i'm not gonna drive to the club i'm
gonna uber anyways if you're in those
states
and you live close to work
maybe you're about that uber life you
save that money now let's get into the
bottom five states and these are the
states that hey maybe i'll keep my car
because car insurance
not that expensive here
um
least expensive so these are the this is
uh number five number five least
expensive is ohio
it's 992 dollars what i knew it was
gonna be some state like that yeah well
there's more that was more of that came
from buddy ohio 992 bucks there we go uh
number
four
least expensive idaho 985 dollars
number three least expensive wisconsin
938 dollars
and then
number nine
new hampshire
dollars and then do you want to guess
the least i'd rather just stay do you
want to guess the least expensive state
out there any guesses out there the
least expensive state kentucky arizona
nope my main man
maine 880 maine is the cheapest state
for car insurance so that's that that's
my little that's a little size tip
little two cents for you
cars are damn expensive they are
depreciating assets
and now more than ever you might want to
consider ditching the car
and doing that uber life you know that
song that goes uber uber uber everywhere
uber everywhere uber everywhere when
that song came out i'm like this is me
dude this is
all we talk me money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken